well first of all I want to thank thank
you all for the opportunity to talk to
you about the subject that I love which
is Christian heart and I'd like to thank
especially father Michael who seems to
do all kinds of things to encourage me
in my work and so today I'm gonna talk
about sacred symbols sacred art how
sacred art what sacred ID looks like
what makes it different from regular art
from contemporary art from modern art so
800 years ago a thousand years ago she
walked into a church any church whether
a church in Jerusalem in Constantinople
in Rome Alexandria or Kiev you might
have felt an eerie connection entering
the nave from the narthex walking in and
peering in east toward the sanctuary
then looking up at the walls at the holy
people depicted there and mostly upon
gazing on that universal image of Christ
you would be connecting to a common
sacred language of art true you might
not be able to read every single
inscription you might not recognize
everybody but most of those image would
be familiar to you a cloud of witnesses
present with you in prayer it's
difficult to know how this comment are
developed they're actually very few
official pronouncement of the church on
what should be in images or what should
be how our vestments should look like
what the architecture is and so this are
developed in quiet and mysterious ways
and no matter how it happened the
grammar the language of Christian art
spread itself from Syria to Spain
creating a common experience a common
experience that was not an identical
experience but unity in a variety as the
common core of imagery was adapted
two local customs and culture all right
we are far from that time now we have
since seen a cascade of conflicts and
changes so profound as to grab on to the
very core of faith itself thoroughly
shaking it until at the end of the 19th
century we were left with almost nothing
but a bit of contempt for that ancient
common Christian art it's difficult to
overemphasize the depth of the changes
that have occurred in the past 500 years
change is so fundamental than when most
people look today at the ancient art at
the early Christian art they're simply
bewildered they don't know what they're
looking at way we live surrounded by
this floating idea that all of early
Christianity until the Renaissance was a
Dark Age out of which we have evolved
progress from a time of superstition and
ignorance a violent and ugly time yes
ugly all right the idea that the Middle
Ages were ugly has wax in wanes but I
remember 20 years ago in my first art
history class I remember being told how
the artists in the Middle Ages had
forgot forgotten in their dark ignorant
you know the classical proportions of
antiquity
and so the Renaissance saved Christian
art right that's what we learned and
maybe not as much today
but I know that's what I learned in my
art history classes and since then the
Revolution seen in the modern age have
been so profound that meaning itself the
way we understand the world the way we
see has changed this dramatically
affects art what its uses what it
represents how and where it represents
it so most of us today don't see the
world in the same way as the ancient
Christians do and yet and yet so many of
us though we don't see the world as the
ancients when we look around us today we
feel a sense of loss a loss of cohesion
a loss of community a loss of meaning
when we look at what calls itself art
today many of us are also bewildered we
are bewildered because we wish we could
find in that art meaning we're looking
for a sense of coming together of a
stable and common language but it's just
not there I don't get me wrong I what
calls itself art today still contains
the grammar of our world but it is a
fragmented language a hermetic ironic
and chaotic language and to most people
this language is simply unintelligent
and so for those of us today who still
have this strange sense that human
activity that human making is important
it feels some uneasiness with what we
see in the contemporary art it might be
useful to ponder the wisdom of the
Ancients and this is what I want to do
with you today right I want to look at
how the ancient Christian world was
framed how its elements of meaning were
brought together to make sense to do
this we need to look at the ancient view
of symbolism what we could call a
Ballack vision of reality itself alright
but before we go on this trip right
there are all kinds of ideas about
symbolism about what it is and what it
isn't and even some Christians
especially certain types of Christians
are suspicious about the word symbolism
right and symbolism they see a kind of
flight of the mind you know what kind of
anything goes where arbitrary meanings
are pasted on top of things and we hear
this all the time right even even I
coming from an orthodox perspective we
hear this even with icons right what
does red mean what does it mean right
we'll say red means blood right red is
blood and it's earth so it represents
humanity the human aspect of Christ but
then maybe red is fire right so it
represents a divinity or maybe red is
fire but maybe it's that other fire all
right and so we're always facing that
kind of thing where where we feel like
meanings are pasted on top of things and
it gets especially frustrating when we
can smell the ideology in someone's
interpretation of something all right
anybody who's read da vinci code will
know what I mean right all right look
you see that Christ and Mary Magdalene
were married isn't it obvious or else
sometimes we get this sense that
symbolism is this phantasmagorical
language right where impossible things
need to be there
right so the clocks are melting so it
must mean something right because
usually clocks don't melt and of course
psychoanalytical ideas have not helped
us either everybody has heard this what
do you see right what does it mean to
you no one's answering so
but there is another maybe even more
pernicious objecting objection to
symbolism this is when symbolism is seen
as a denial of what is there right a
denial of the truth of something I'm
sure we've all encountered this it's
actually fascinating because in this
view of symbolism
we're meaning as a denial of factual
truth we will find the most conservative
you know Bible Belt type person and the
most progressive post Christian type
acting like two sides of a single coin
and so let's flip the coin tails right
fundamentalist the story of Moses is the
story of Moses right it talks about what
Moses did what God did right don't tell
me that Moses in the basket on the on
the river means something right can't
mean something or else it wouldn't be
true right it wouldn't have happened if
you turn the coin again heads
progressive we can see in the story of
Moses that there are structures right we
know that sargon of akkad Cyrus the
Great
even Romulus were put in a basket on
water to later become the leader of
their people so right it can't be true
right it's a myth it can't be true
because it has meaning and of course I'm
presenting the extremes to make a point
but I'm sure everybody here has met them
grizzled fighters from both sides of
this meaning war and it seems like in
the media we always hear these two
extremes sadly but
these two positions one denying symbolic
meaning in the name of truth or
factuality and another denying all
factuality in the name of structure and
symbolism that we see in the stories are
really essentially the same there are
both a dividing of fact and meaning a
split of mind and body heads and tails
art versus science but the problem is
that factuality the world out there is a
funny thing the world is composed of an
infinity of details a stream of flowing
events and in some ways Heraclitus was
right the world around us is a flowing
river so what makes us cut into that
what makes us cut into the flow and pick
out a few specifics out of the myriad of
floating factoids around us right I
could write a hundred page essay on my
big toe right I could describe every
crease every pore every hair and then I
could describe every single change of my
big toe from my birth until today so in
fact I could write a 1000 page book on
my big toe right but I don't do that
I don't do that because it's meaningless
because it doesn't matter as human
beings we separate out and pull together
elements from the fleeting world and
engage with them to the extent that they
are meaningful to the extent that they
express at least something in common
with other images other stories that are
important but it is in fact pure madness
to suggest a story would not be true
because we see in it some structure
something in common some contrast with
other stories right that commonality
with other stories is the very reason we
noticed it in the first place
right why we noticed a particular person
rather than all the cloud of people next
to him doing a million things and having
nothing not noticeable about them and so
just before I continue on this I want to
give I want to give everybody a
permission tonight this is especially
true for people who are still in college
because you we get a lot of this next
time someone tells you that Christ's
life resembles some story a Greek myth
or a Hindu mythology of every other
story in the Old Testament all right
just say yes yes he is yes it is in fact
that's why Christ is the focus of
millions of people's lives that's why
I'm talking about Christ and not about
this guy right who's that Tim Hortons
playing Minecraft on his phone right
that's and when I talk about Christ I
talk about it in a way that emphasizes
that meaning right I am NOT interested
in a book detailing the length of his
tunic or discussions among the Apostles
about who was gonna carry who why
they're walking right st. John said that
if all the things that Christ had done
in his life had been written down the
world itself could not contain the books
that would be written
so in this light look at this icon right
look at this icon in which all the
elements of the story of the crucifixion
are put together even across time so the
story is not a snapshot of a moment
right but it's a gathering of all the
substantial elements from within the
whole story itself all right now notice
the difference between this icon and
this painting by the the Dutch painter
Carl von maunder
all right the crucifixion is a small
detail in a complicated composition
right the central most visible space is
held by a vendor
the modern world starting at the end of
the Middle Ages but ramping up the
stakes until the 18th 19th century has
increasingly separated body and mind
fact and meaning signifier signifies but
if we look back if we look back at the
ancients we will find something much
different
interestingly enough the word symbol
itself the Greek word from which it is
derived means a coming together right
literally it means to throw together
right but that's just Greeks being
dramatic so don't worry about that in
the Bible the word symbol is often used
to describe the meeting of people to
people meeting on a road or a discussion
conferring together and so this coming
together can also be a type of
laboratory a place where these diverse
things are looking to sort things out to
find the heart of the matter but we
still use that meaning today but for
example what we call the symbol of the
Apostles what is that
it's the Creed in which all the basic
elements of the Christian faith faith
are pointed out they're pointed out from
the thousands of things that Christian
can and do believe and they're pulled
into one place in an image in a token of
our faith and of the church and so the
symbol and a traditional vision is a
sign right that's how we're used to
thinking of symbols right we're used to
thinking of symbols as signs the green
light the little figure on the lavatory
door but in this sense the symbol is a
sign only and that it is an actual
manifestation of what the sign points to
all right and that is what I am
suggesting to you today that this type
of symbolism is really the ancient
vision of symbolism
the ancient vision of how meaning exists
in the world right in the Bible there is
a very beautiful use of the word symbol
right it's in a text in the Gospel of
st. Luke Luke 2:19 after all the events
of the birth of Christ
it says upon hearing the stories of the
Shepherd's Mary gathered all these
things bringing them sorry gathered all
these things pondering them in her heart
so the word ponder that we translate
ponder is symbol it's actually Symbolics
the verb form so she is gathering and
bringing together symbolizing in her
heart in her Center all of these things
and so really if I was going to give you
one definition of what Christian
symbolism is that would be it right
there gathering what is around us
picking out what is meaningful right
taking from the matter the facts the raw
events separate out and picking out from
all that potential what is meaningful
and bringing all together within the
heart to create coherence to create a
story or an image all right there are
some Church Fathers really starting in
the Gospel of st. John itself we're
beyond storytelling and commentary gives
us the view of reality itself right not
in a scientific vision but in a
metaphysical one how man language
creation all come together in relating
to the divine right one of these church
fathers is called st. Maximus the
Confessor and he's a bit less known in
the West but in the Orthodox Church he
is one of the main proponents he's one
of the main thinkers about what it is
what does the Christian world look like
and for anybody here was interested in
art or symbolism or meaning I would urge
you to look into st. Maximus his
writings they're really some of the most
profound things written in the history
of Christianity right st. Maximus in his
writings expands greatly on the notion
of logos right the word at the beginning
of st. John's Gospel in the beginning
was the word and the Word was with God
and the Word was God
that notion of logos before st. John
used it had a very very charged meaning
he had a long history with the Greek
philosophers with the Roman philosophers
it meant spoken word of course right in
the most common sense or in the sense of
God said let there be light like just
spoken word but it also meant reason
reason in both the ways we use the word
today that is reason as the origin the
purpose and the goal right the reason I
cut my hair is my new job but I don't
have to do that because I'm an artist
so the logos is the origin the purpose
and the goal of all things right that's
what we believe as Christians we can say
that Christ is the origin the purpose
and the goal of all things but in the
ancient meaning of logos it also
contained the other way we use the word
reason that is reason as the source of
logic right reason as the source of
reasoning we still see the word logos in
a word logic but here we have to see it
in the sense of the middle right imagine
reason as a balanced logos as the
mediator of divisions the mediator of
opposites that which brings together but
all told also that which separates right
this might seem like a paradox right
that which brings together but also that
which separates but really it's not
complicated it's actually quite
yes think about a mediator in the strict
sense but in the most common sense
imagine a fight in a couple right what
does a mediator do the mediator stands
between both to separate so you don't
rip each other's faces off but also to
bring them together to ultimately find a
common ground and for Christians in the
case of Christ
the mediator himself is the common
ground to understand that the logos the
Word of God that which separated heaven
and earth in the beginning is also that
which United heaven and earth in Christ
is crucial to all of Christians
symbolism and to a vision of Christian a
Christian vision of reality itself that
is why st. Paul can tell us that God was
in Christ reconciling the world to
himself right uniting on a vertical
level and on the horizontal level there
are countless examples of Christ uniting
one of the examples is in the conflict
between the Jews and the chapel
st. Paul tells us that he Christ is our
peace who has made the two groups one
the Jews and the Gentiles brought
together to be one his purpose was to
create in himself one new humanity out
of the two thus making peace and in one
body to reconcile both of them to God
through the cross so we can see both
movements in that verse right uniting
the Jews and the Gentiles and then
reconciling up to God the vertical and
the horizontal that is the cross so
Christ is peace but the same logos the
same word of God is said in the Epistle
of the Hebrews to be sharper than a
two-edged sword it penetrates even to
dividing soul and spirit joint and
marrow Christ said I have not come to
bring peace but the sword the mediator
is also a judge and no one likes that
image of Christ any more where we're not
actually supposed to talk about it
but beyond the sentimentality right of
wanting this of wanting our buddy Christ
we need to have a deeper vision right if
you want to see in the Bible and the
father's and in Christian art what
meaning is how meaning comes about how
the world was made and how we in God's
image are makers of things we need to
have a deeper vision so coming back to
st. Maximus in his cosmic vision
everything has a logos so Christ is the
logos but everything in the world has a
logos for something to even exist right
for it to be pulled out of the void it
must have some reason right it has been
named it has been called out there must
be let there be
food or let there be father Mychal right
there has to be a calling out so say
Maximus would tell us would tell us that
one does not consider anything of what
is visible in the world as impure
because he does not find any
irreconcilable contradiction with the
ideas of things so what he means idea of
things read logos the purpose of things
so nothing in the world is impure when
it is seen through its purpose through
its reason - its logos all right
so say Maximus tells this is gonna be
the most complicated quote I promise
after that it'll get easier you need to
lay the base first right so Maximus
tells us that everything in the universe
is separated from one another in an
orderly manner in accordance with the
logo logo is just plural for logo so the
many reasons the many purposes in which
each thing consists by the ineffable one
who holds and protects everything in
accordance I'm gonna unpack this notice
in this quote the double movement right
I talked about the mediator as being as
both separating and uniting I say
Maximus tells us that everything is
separated according to logo according to
the multiplicity of reasons they have
for existing the multiplicity of
purposes right this is a chair this is
the color blue this is joy and all of
this diversity consists by the ineffable
won the ultimate logos the capital L
logos the uncreated second person of the
Trinity who holds everything in
accordance with unity and gives it its
ultimate sense and that double movement
right the uniting and the separating the
push the the pushing away and the not
push point but the uniting and is
separating when both of those when those
are done both simultaneously when there
is both division and bringing together
for st. Maximus that is love
love is when I give myself to another
completely utterly without dissolving
into that other without the other
dissolving into me
but by being United with you I let you
be completely other for me now that is
love and that is the very life of God
the very life of the Divine Trinity it
is the highest image of the infinite
absolute one absolute many completely
United completely divided being and
non-being together in love so everything
leads to that all our vision of what and
how things are meaningful as Christians
originate in that love all right
I've gone as high as I'm gonna go right
I'm not going higher than the Trinity so
we're gonna come back down now we need
to land on both feet okay we started
this with art and so we're gonna come
back to art I want to talk about art and
I want to talk about it using an icon
the icon of Christ
looking at this icon will help us see
the process of symbolism more closely
it'll show us by an example how it works
and how meaning appears this is of
course a famous image of Christ right
probably the most famous image of Christ
in the world right now right is one of
the first panel icons we have from the
sixth century and it's in Egypt at the
monastery of st. Catherine's it's an
image of Christ as Penn Tokra tour which
means Christ as the ruler of all things
it's Christ at the end right it's Christ
as he is returning when all things are
resolved when everything has come to its
end
all right I'm sure that everybody has
noticed something off about this icon
and look at the eyes
Christ's right eye is looking straight
and his left eye is looking away and
down right some people think this is a
mistake right and sometimes you see
artists reproduce this image and they
fix it but although this this these
different eyes is not in every single
icon I want to show you something
here's a mosaic from Constantinople
from the 13th century 700 years later I
look at the eyes and here this is the
drawing for a dome that was done last
year in California
there's an ancient tradition according
to Evagrius
so early which says that the right eye
is for contemplating God and the left
eye is for contemplating creation in the
Sinai image the left eye of Christ is
also severe right
the eyebrow is coming down and so the
traditional interpretation is that the
right eye of Christ is the eye of Mercy
the eye of peace and the left eye of
Christ is the eye of rigor the sword in
the Gospel of Matthew we read when the
Son of man shall come in his glory and
all the holy angels with him then he
shall sit upon his throne of glory and
before him shall be gathered all the
nations and he shall separate them one
from another as a shepherd divides his
sheep from the goats and he shall set
the sheep on his right and the goats on
his left then the king shall say unto
them on the right hand come you blessed
of my father and he shall say to them on
the left hand depart from me this
gathering together of everything is
referenced many places in the gospel
Christ also says it in regards to the
harvest where the wheat and the chaff
are all brought together and then they
are separated the wheat is gathered in
to the barn and the chaff is cast away
into the fire right I hope some of you
are seeing where I'm going this notice
the two movements I have been alluding
to from the beginning of my talk
gathering separating the very manner in
which I suggested the world exists this
is what the logos does both in creating
the world and in resolving the finality
of the world
in the Sinai image we can see how the
artist participated in this structure he
participated in this structure by
painting it into the image itself and so
this image this image of the Pantocrator
this image of the final christ of the
returning christ will become also the
image in the Last Judgement where is
made explicit this process of gathering
in and raising up with the right and
pushing away and down with the left I
noticed in this image it is no longer
his eyes but his hands which suggests
the two movements it shows us what the
Prophet Simeon said about Christ behold
this child is destined for the fall and
the rising of many in Israel so if we
look at how it appears in the gospel and
in the icons the opposition of left and
right in the image and the symbolism it
evokes are not arbitrary but this is not
creative or innovative right in the
special sense we've given to those words
today it is anchored in the reality that
all humans have a strong dexterous hand
and in 95% of people the right hand is
the strong hand and the left hand is the
weekend is the wayward one so before I
go too far with this I just want to tell
you that I am left-handed all right
so anything I say from now on applies to
me but I have a surprise for the lefties
in the audience just pay attention it's
coming this has created certain
universal and inevitable social
structures for example in almost all
traditional cultures one eats with the
right hand and when washes with the left
so when gathers to oneself with the
right and when separates and pushes the
away from himself with the left so right
we'll come to mean straight I dare all
the right-handed people to try to write
with their left hand it won't be
straight right right we'll come to mean
straight right that's the ortho the
ortho of Orthodoxy or orthodontists
right making teeth straight in French
it's very explicit dois means both right
and straight and so left will mean
crooked also multiple in the sense of
divided right will be wise and left will
be foolish in the Bible in the book of
Ecclesiastes it says the heart of the
wise inclines to the right but the heart
of the fool to the left but Christ right
Christ the logos is the mediator of
opposites right so where is his heart
look again at the eyes now idea in the
middle christ has both the straight and
the crooked all right this will go
further than you can imagine there is a
much later tradition which says that
when Christ was on the cross his left
foot was twisted when it was nailed down
and you can see that in some icons I
look at the knee look at how the knees
face to the right but the foot is
twisted to the left this is one of my
carvings but it's based on ancient
models so this structure of left and
right will multiply itself in
traditional Christian imagery it will
form a part of the world view the
underlying mesh the web which holds
meaning together right and so in the
crucifixion the good thief who
recognized Christ will be placed on the
right the bad deep who mocked him
we place on the left and this will
become the most widely accepted
explanation for the Russian three barred
cross the cross where the foots the
footrest is slanted and you can see that
in this image like a balance with the
right side going up and the left going
down but as we move deeper into the
symbolism we will see that because
gathering in and pushing away are not
necessarily good and bad right the
meaning will become far more
encompassing and this will elevate
Christian symbolism beyond moral duality
so for example st. Peter will come to
represent the right right he is the
fisherman who gathers the fish at the
miraculous catch in the Gospel of st.
John Christ says to Peter put your net
on the right side from which he gathers
the abundance of fish st. Peter is the
first apostle the first to recognize
Christ as the Messiah he is an image of
the foundation and he is also the
apostle to the Jews God's first chosen
people so you can imagine them that st.
Paul will be associated to the left he
is a Roman citizen he's the apostle to
the Gentiles to the foreigners those
that are far away he is the last of the
Apostle he's the 13th apostle coming
after the fact and in his own words he
boasts of his weakness he says he is the
least of the Apostles he talks about the
folly of Christ but now in his writings
this Farley this being last is
transformed and becomes the highest
attainment of a Christian right I
mentioned briefly that the left will
come to mean drunkenness
but look at the wine on the left here
right is it for drunkenness or is it for
the highest mystery continuing the
pattern we will find the mother of God
on the right of Christ both Saint John
the Baptist and st. John the Apostle on
the Left of Christ Adam on the right Eve
on the left now let's look at that again
the church fathers often say that Eve at
the fall broke the unity of the nature
of humanity and separated the one nature
into a myriad of individuals and now the
mother of God United all that humanity
brought it together in her womb in the
person of Christ
and now look down at the balance at the
scale on the same axis as Christ and the
cross the mediator of opposites and it
is extremely important to understand
that this structure is not just a good
bad structure st. Maximus who've been
looking at he'll be our guide through
this talks about the sins of the right
hand now what do you think those are he
tells us that the passions of the flesh
may be described as belonging to the
left self conceit as belonging to the
right hand so now we can see this
gathering in to oneself we can see how
this can become dangerous as well so if
in st. Paul we saw the positive aspect
of the left side the foolishness the
being last as something positive in st.
Peter we might be able to see the
opposite the negative aspects of the
right hand right what is it that st.
Peter said that made Christ rebuked him
that made Christ tell him get behind me
Satan Saint Peter said that Christ would
not die Saint Peter said he would never
deny Christ right those are the sins of
the right hand
saint-michel tell us that the demons
that compat it combat us by the lack of
virtue are those that teaches
prostitution and drunkenness greed and
jealousy the demon that combat us with
excess of virtue are those that teach us
presumption vainglory and who by the
vices of the right secretly placed in us
the vices of the left so actually the
sin of the right is the first sin the
sin of Adam it's the sin of the evil one
and so that's my revenge of the lefty by
the way but Christ would go to the end
of the right and to the left and he
himself would reach down to the lowest
and rise up to the highest on the cross
that is Christian symbolism so if we
look at our buddy Christ image again
what do we see with his right eye shut
and his big silly grin Christ is in the
middle this is not an image of Christ
it's just a fool once you begin to look
at this structure right this particular
structure of left and right or the
numerous other structures which create
the symbolic web of sacred stories there
are many many other of these this is
just one you can spend your entire life
meditating on the subtlety and the
complexity and the reversions in this
but coming to this symbolism is coming
to the structure of reality itself right
it is not literary it is not a type of
flight of the mind right it is not the
anything-goes which critics of symbolism
will evoke there is no copyright on this
symbolism nobody can claim it and if it
is somehow constructed in the images in
the art it is only so that we can dive
deeper into the mysteries of creation
and the mysteries of God how as st. Paul
tells us God's invisible attributes are
clearly seen being understood by the
things that are made even his eternal
power and Godhead and so what is
Christian art
I would like to suggest that if we are
going to speak of a truly Christian art
it is not just art with religious
subjects Christian art is not only art
made by people who call themselves
Christian Christian art is that art
which imitates and participates in the
logos in the separating and orderly
gathering of elements and gathering
towards a purpose a Christian art does
not just point to a polemical moral
meaning but is embedded with the rich
complex and powerful structure which
lead us deeper into the mysteries of God
and I am a liturgical artist in the
Orthodox tradition and in an orthodox
frame of worship the paintings the
architecture the music the vestments
everything refers to each other they
explain and exemplify each other their
shapes their forms their narratives
their structures and it creates a cosmic
web of analogies you know and that web
culminates into Christ in the dome they
culminate into that moment of communion
into the very reason why we are there in
that church and I know this is painful
for artists often to hear but the
language of contemporary art and of
contemporary culture is there to do the
very opposite of this contemporary art
is an explosion of thousands of personal
artistic processes in languages each
more broken and hermetic than the other
where is the symbol where is the coming
together are gone is the mysterious
unity that I spoke of
at the outset of an art that connects
Syria to Russia to Italy to Spain you
see the language of contemporary art has
its own logos in a way right maybe it's
more of an anti logos but still there is
an ironic coherence in the language used
so it has a force by which the content
and the intent in the art are united -
the language used to express them all
right in early modern art we had a
language that was revolutionary that was
there to break the old traditions that
was there to destroy the Christian
heritage that had been there before
right it was an art coming at the
beginning of the century where Europe
was poised on two world wars and
contemporary art in the wake of that
revolution is no longer revolutionary it
is rather decomposing fragmenting
contemporary art from the highest
gallery art to the blockbuster Hollywood
movie is interested in the banal the
contradictory the grotesque
the transgressive it is full of irony
and deflation sentimentality
exaggeration and at this point I am NOT
even criticizing it
that is what contemporary art is right
what I'm showing you these are the top
artists of our world but I am NOT
picking picking and choosing for these
if you read an art magazine these are
the people that they're talking about so
that is contemporary art and those that
understand this they do it wonderfully
and no Christian on earth could ever
come close to Jeff Koons
Plato sculpture at the in New York at
the Getty
or to Quentin Tarantino or Frank Gehry
and even in the most popular cultural
manifestations really who would rather
listen to some derivative Christian rock
band rather than listen to the Beatles
or to Nirvana right when artists who are
Christian take up the language of
contemporary art of high art or popular
music and music they often do it in a
naive and not so thought out desire to
be with the times right they seem to
rarely understand the ramifications of
the art they make and the languages they
employ languages of disjunction and
provocation and entertainment
alright this crucifix is in a church
it's made with coat hangers so there's a
pun right hanging on the cross it's a
what is this solution what is this
solution for someone with faith who
wants to make things right who doesn't
want to be mindlessly conservative for
that matter mindlessly innovative who
wants to act with coherence with a
coherent language with a coherent
purpose right I believe this solution is
is something isn't something akin to
symbolism the solution is in is what is
what I have described as the process of
symbolism to be since the beginning of
this talk right the ancient notion of
art the word art itself means fitting
together that's what it means
alright in the Middle Ages there was no
difference between high art and low art
there was no difference between craft
and art the word in Greek for art is
techn a tech Navy have in our word
technology so in the ancient sense there
was not this high art there was as much
an art of painting as an art of poetry
architecture making beer anything
was pulling things together and making
you see as the modern world separated
body and mind it also separated art and
technology high art lower and by
attempting to create a fine art an art
which elevates itself to the highest and
purest language we can see we can chart
it we can chart modern art becoming more
and more elitist esoteric and
disassociated to any kind of
participation in society right art
objects became simply things to look at
with no use whatsoever right we say that
today visual arts making things to look
at so we put them in galleries and
museums because unless you're very rich
there's no other way to see these things
and in contrast an icon for example is a
visual object but it is fully integrated
into the life of the church it's part of
the liturgy a tool of prayer an
instrument of teaching it's not just a
decoration or just there to be art but
this idea that we can create pure beauty
pure art art for art's sake it has that
side effect separating itself and so the
lower part becomes technology it becomes
the product
and more and more of that lower part of
the art of the ancient art became
objects for use and consuming that have
no transcendence beauty and
transcendence of transcendence aren't
part of it and if we try to make them
beautiful it's only so that people will
buy them and consume them but Christian
art should be incarnation 'el that is
uniting the highest with the lowest
uniting the purposes the logo of things
with the things in the world not useless
objects of aesthetic pleasure right it
does not mean that an integrated art
will not be beautiful or will not bring
pleasure but it is anchored in the
purposeful it is the difference between
eating a good meal with your family and
friends and binging on chocolate cake at
one o'clock in the morning and if we can
recapture this ancient vision of art an
art that is purposeful and the first
thing it will do is give us artists a
bit more humility right it will pull us
in from our sins of the right hand and
we can no longer be the genius artists
that all adore it also means that we
will act with purpose and these purposes
will reign in our wild left hand so we
will avoid the excesses of unbridled
expression and provocation and irony all
right let's be careful though when I say
purpose I don't mean purpose in
convincing you know like an
advertisement or some bad Christian
movie right what do I mean by purpose
right my last point let's look at this
is it possible to find the purpose of
modern art is it possible to convert it
st. Maximus tells us that
I didn't see this way okay modern and
contemporary art we have two extremes
alright there's many extremes but we can
frame it this way one of the extremes is
simplifying abstracting right let's say
the right hand right and on the other
hand there is an extreme in multiplying
in mixing in irony let's call that the
left hand what if we ask ourselves what
is the purpose of these two tendencies
right if we believe what's a Maximus
said but if we believe that as she says
many things which are good in themselves
are not good because of the motive for
which they are done so we can we find
the original purpose why would we
simplify things do we is it not to
emphasize the purity the simplicity the
oneness we could say that in reducing
the noise simplicity wants to get to the
essence right it is that gathering in of
the right hand way we can use this as
artists trying to cut to the basics
right you can warn us of the dangers
when meanings are lost in excess of
ornament excess of colour excess of
composition and I think this is
something which exists today as a
movement in many contemporary liturgical
artists that I know right ultimately the
desire towards simplicity is to be an
image of the unity of God and the unity
of the person of Jesus Christ
it's only when it's taken to unbalanced
extremes where multiplicity is forgotten
that this desire for purity will give
birth to the modern monsters that we saw
in the 20th and 21st century religious
religious extremism
or even Nazism right what is not
seasoned but the desire for purity to
cut off the margins it's only that in
this case we're talking about people and
in art this extreme purification will
leave lead to minimalism we just saw
that in the black square on the wall in
which the art is so simplified that
there's nothing human left about it
there's no place to breathe
all right so back to the left hand what
is the purpose of multiplying and
showing diversity right is it not to
show complexity abundance and movement
is it not to show the dynamics of change
or we can also use that as artists be
sensitive to it and avoid a frozen
monolithic art and to make sure that art
is integrated into the specifics and
locale of different cultures it could
even show us the mystical possibilities
of the limit the mystical possibilities
of the Holy fool but this can be done
only in balance with unity this
understanding of multiplicity and
complexity is also a movement in many
contemporary liturgical artists I know
and ultimately this desire towards
complexity is anchored in the diversity
of persons in God the duality of the
nature's of Christ it is only when taken
to extremes and forgetting unity that it
becomes the fragmented highly confused
and individualistic Democrat democracies
we live in or the mad desire the
consumerism the irony and the excess of
so much contemporary culture so maybe
the question asked by artists musicians
writers should no longer be how as
Christians we can make art or music or
literature that is more in step with the
modern world right how we can attract
modern people by being modern but rather
without falling into blind
conservativism we should once again look
and try to express look for and tried to
express the logos in all we do the
hidden purposes whether it is in
liturgical art or a more secular art we
need to ask ourselves how the use of
what we are making
how the materials the forms the subjects
and the styles all fit with each other
and participate in the logos and so
become even if indirectly a place where
God's invisible attributes are clearly
seen being understood by the things that
are made this means that we will anchor
ourselves in our traditions and those
patterns and structures I have alluded
to from the beginning and those will be
our guide and ultimately Christ will be
our guide to pull out of contemporary
art to pull out of contemporary culture
those things which fit and so that's my
vision for you today right that is the
path that I have set for myself in my
own art right and so I hope if it might
seem too extreme too crazy to some or
maybe too conservative to others I will
have provoked a process of thought which
hopefully will bring a balance of how
the Church of Christ relates to art so
hard we make in the art we see thank you